where does from the leader perspective
uh things like narcissism or sociopathy
psychopathy come into play
what can you make of
the world we live in maybe the leaders
that run the world from the perspective
from the lens of narcissism so I am
struck 20 years of doing
what I do now I've been a psychiatrist
for 20 years and I practiced in so many
different settings and I consult in
different settings I've been fortunate
to have a very wide purview of like
what's going on in people and in the
world around us and I am struck with
amazement that of all the things I see
that I say abnormal let's say from the
mental health perspective this could be
depression panic attacks uh hearing
voices addiction but there's so many
things that cover everything
that narcissism is not
frequent compared to a lot of other
things so it's it's it's small in terms
of their narcissistic diagnosis right
it's it's much less than many other
things but it causes the Lion's Share I
don't just mean the most compared to
anything else but but I think more than
50 the majority of
bad things evil things destructive
things that I that I see in the world
around us I think narcissists are wildly
destructive because they are driven
completely they are lodged completely in
the lane of
Envy
can you um try to sneak up and we don't
want to be lost in definitions but can
you try to sneak up to a definition
non-clinical definition of narcissism
that we're talking about so narcissism
is a deep
pervasive and unquestioned sense of
inadequacy in the self that comes along
with anger and fear and vulnerability
fear of Destruction fear of annihilation
that is compensated for by
aggression by is it by the the mechanics
of Envy by trying to make the self uh
seem better at the expense of others by
taking from others uh by being
completely Cavalier to the thoughts and
feelings of others that narcissism is
not arrogance now narcissism is the
opposite of arrogance there is such a
deep sense of inadequacy and
incompetence in the self that the
defensive structure around that becomes
dominated by rocket fueled Envy
so the Machinery of narcissism is Envy
but uh what do you make of the kind of
more popularly discussed kind of symptom
of narcissism which is a seeming
not caring about other people
sort of a very inward facing focus in
terms of the calculation you make when
making decisions about the world
narcissistic people definitely care
about other people right it's the people
who are schizoid right and say that
don't care don't necessarily register
other people right but narcissism people
care about other people but it's
entirely vis-a-vis the self right if I'm
schizoid I don't really notice or care
much who you are right but if I'm
narcissistic I absolutely care because
I'm watching every last detail of you
what might you have that's better than
me yeah right it's it's an it's an
incredibly intense focus upon
individuals and demographics of people
but the priority the the goal is
entirely about the self which is why
that can become easy to say I don't care
if a million people die right that's how
different is that from going out and
destroying one person or a million
people right it's it's in the same
category of those people only there
existing is only meaningful in how it
relates to me
but it's still
meaningful it just seems like a very
difficult uh leap to take that I don't
care that a million people die
that
seems to be even with Envy
that seems to be a big
like feeling and thought to have if you
at all care about them
are other people I guess
tools for alleviation of your sense of
inadequacy right I mean I don't even
care about in that like being caring at
all I mean caring about in that noticing
that the person exists right I mean
someone who wants money and and notices
that there's a hundred dollar bill out
cares about that or they don't care
about the the hundred dollar bill and
that doesn't mean anything to them it
doesn't have thoughts and feelings but
but it's going to attract attention they
care about it because it's something
that they want right the same way people
will care about others but only from the
perspective of do you have things that I
want or can I feel better about myself
by taking something from you by making
things worse for you people often talk
about narcissism as like the opposite of
empathy
uh-huh but sort of empathy again depends
how you define it but it's a
is a is a careful consideration
of the mental space of another person of
how the other person sees the world
and and so you're kind of saying that
narcissism narcissistic people would be
also be very good at that
in in order to understand
how maybe the other person can be
manipulated or something to alleviate
your sense of inadequacy right so
there's a difference between the
mechanics of empathy so let's say again
we can Define things different ways
let's say empathic Attunement is the
ability to be attuned and to think okay
what's going on in you what might you be
thinking what might you be feeling some
people have a lot of empathic Attunement
but that's a that's we could look at
that as mechanistic right it doesn't it
doesn't equate to care right an empathic
Attunement
can come along with empathy or not
right so so yes people who are
narcissistic they they can mentalize
well so you mentalize meaning the
ability to to understand or to consider
thoughts feelings motivations and other
people right so so people who are
narcissistic can have empathic
Attunement or mentalization depending
upon how we want to describe those
things but that has nothing to do with
care with actual empathy or kindness or
or consideration so in that sense
empathy usually popularly used means
that you care like your happiness is
aligned this is uh I need to read this
book I've read so little science fiction
that's been one of my goals for this
year to catch up on some science fiction
so uh Robert Highland uh from Stranger
in a Strange Land has this quote about
love which is love is that condition
where another person's happiness is is
essential to your own so that's a good
definition I guess of empathy where yes
you're very sensitive so mechanistically
very sensitive to the state of another
person's mind
and your goal is to maximize their
happiness it's like essential to your
own happiness so the the happinesses are
aligned and when that's like elevated to
its highest forms you can call that law
of romantic love friendship and so on
okay okay so one more thing about the
nurses some people can be sort of benign
narcissists where they want great things
for themselves right but if they have
enough great things they can sort of
tolerate others being happy too and and
these are people who sometimes are
actually quite highly liked right
because they have to have the most money
the most power the most of anything
anything more than anyone else could
challenge but as long as I have that
it's okay that you have some too right
and then that can make you happy and can
make you like me right so so benign
narcissists can be can be well liked
from that perspective but
it's still all about them and that can
change if for example there's a scarcity
of resources now right but but they're
generally they're not people who are
being overtly destructive although that
they're over the border into the you
know into the Envy territory right
malignant narcissists are very different
where they then want to have everything
so they so even if I have a thousand
times more than you do I Still Envy you
what you have because I want to have I
don't think I can feel good enough about
myself unless I have everything and once
I have everything I won't feel good
enough about myself either and I don't
have to have more right it's like that's
malignant narcissism which we we think
of as sociopathy right as we can we can
Define these words in different ways but
they're very very negative Concepts you
know it's that's that's profound
sociopathy malignant narcissism uh you
know Envy writ large sociopathy is
malignant narcissism that's a convenient
way to think about it
uh no because we can do sort of
sociopathic things that but not be
sociopathic like well you know I tell a
white lie it's it's like sort of
sociopathy on steroids right is is then
you know Envy writ large is malignant
narcissists well just like you're saying
like there's empathic Attunement as you
said so there's the the mechanistic
aspect of empathy and sociopathy and
then there's the big label you get
attached if you're just doing that thing
regularly I guess living your life
through that lens yeah right yeah and uh
is there a nice Spectrum that's like
narcissism sociopathy and psychopathy is
it all the same kind of a nice stroll
through the woods off the cliff not
really because the words don't have
clear definitions like psychopathy and
sociopathy there's no there's no there's
no real definition of psychopath or
psychopathy or does that mean someone's
sociopathic but psychotic like there's
really not a we end up using those words
colloquially right which is why you know
Concepts that we can Define like you
like Envy empathic Attunement
um narcissism even though there might be
nuances and definitions like we can
Define them in ways that are widely
accepted including within psychology and
Psychiatry so it's nice to just think
about this a broad umbrella of
narcissism and the levels to which it's
benign or malignant and then also
separating into the different mechanisms
like interaction by interaction which
sometimes can be narcissistic but
broadly speaking do you do everything
through the lens of malignant narcissism
that makes you a
sociopath or
a malignant narcissist yes and the thing
I would I would add to that is the
thought about culture right it's like
how does the the cultures were in
whether it's the culture of a household
right the culture of a community the
culture of a Nation or the world right
how does that impact what unfolds in
that person and then how does what
unfolds in that person impact that
culture well that's the the question is
what unfolds in that person
yeah how is culture affected but how
does your own psychological development
unfold that because narcissism in
leaders is the most impactful thing
right who are the most impactful
individuals what is the most impact of
individual psychology we have it's
usually leaders of countries or leaders
of major organizations and so on and one
of the things you mentioned with benign
narcissism it's that seems to be aligned
with success right if you care about
your own success
that that's going to be you're more
likely to be have narcissistic
Tendencies I suppose
um and so my question is when you
follow that threat of narcissism to
become the leader of a country
now you have a lot of new interesting
psychological complexities to deal with
like power that old cliche that power
corrupts
does that is it possible for power to
corrupt the human mind to where it
pushes you farther and farther
into a malignant narcissism into this
destructive Envy what are your thoughts
on power like the effect of power in the
human mind yeah
power is
um
let's say an accentuator right an
intensifier right so so I think it is
true that there are people who can be
sort of in a gray area where there are
malignant narcissistic Tendencies and
and behaviors but there are also ways in
which that person can think outside of
themselves and think in a broader way
and and think sort of kindly about
others and and they're they're sort of
trying to navigate whether they're aware
or not that they're trying to navigate
between one and the other and then the
Allure of power is well just look just
exercise that power and you'll feel
better right you're gonna it'll show you
right that you're good enough look at
the power you have and whatever may be
going on in the person's mind that then
power yes can corrupt yes I think that's
why we we have to have checks and
balances right because we don't you know
we we are all inscrutable to ourselves
let alone to others so so we must have
checks and balances and we should always
have them on ourselves as well as on
others we should we should want that for
the health of ourselves in the world
around us
um so I think all of that is true but
there are also people who don't
necessarily become corrupted by power
right that there can be an understanding
and a grounding uh that they're a
steward of power right uh you know a
Shepherd you know I mean the ways people
describe utilizing power and utilizing
it a benign what it in a benign way that
then Fosters the healthy aspects of self
right so like gratitude and humility
right if I mean if we if we could add a
healthy dose of gratitude and humility
to everyone or to our society there
would be a sea change right but how do
you how do you feel gratitude how do you
feel humility those things are
incompatible with narcissism Envy right
with really the bad pole of things that
we're talking about and part of the
reason I you know I'm so focused in my
work and really what runs through all of
my thoughts about life is that the
impact of trauma right because trauma
you know creates these false lessons and
it walls us off from truth then and you
know it starts to point towards the the
unhealthy ways of
um of trying to feel better about
ourselves but we have the health in US
too we have those Seeds of Health too
that can grow into being a steward of
power and sharing power being
considerate and kind and we see a lot of
that in the world too right it's not all
just the evil we you know we see plenty
of people who do good and who are
generous of spirit and you know we have
both in us and it is I think you're
talking about our culture and what the
seeds that we sow and and the climate
that we set including putting Governors
and boundaries around like how do we how
do we rein in or say that the more
aggressive the more envious or
destructive is unacceptable right how do
we Foster the the part that's kind and
considerate and reflective and and slow
to judge of like hey let's learn a
little bit more like how do we Foster
that and I think a lot of that comes
back to early childhood education I mean
I think we don't do nearly enough to
protect children and and as a corollary
to that we don't do nearly enough to
educate children and we said I want to
write a book second book I write is
gonna it's gonna be everything I needed
to know about life I learned as a second
year postgraduate Psychiatry residents I
was like why you know why then did I
learn so much about unconscious
motivation about the impact of trauma
about how we can be envious and how we
can act out you know even about how our
emotions Trump logic in us like what why
why don't we teach these things when
we're young enough to understand like
why is that other kid bullying me right
or why just because I'm a little bit
bigger do I want to go thump that other
kid on the head like what what what's
going on that we don't we don't do those
things you know we just we're tripping
ahead of ourselves and we don't stop and
think how are we using our resources how
are we how are we shepherding forward
the Next Generation which by the way is
a generation that's going to determine
our Fates too right as we get older but
we don't you know do that I often think
of like in the Olympics you know you see
like the the great sprinters right and
they've got to come out of the blocks
perfectly right because if they come out
of the blocks a little bit too fast
they're going to fall over right they're
going to just fall forward and and I I
often see that in my head about us as
you know as humans and as a culture that
we're rushing so far forward we don't
stop and say wait let's let's keep the
basics here the basic techniques of like
how are we navigating forward in in Life
or do we just throw all those away
because I can get some benefit by
saying that you're bad even though
what's being leveled against you is
wrong right like what why why do do I
take that or do I say no there's
something more important here that we
want to Shepherd forward in ourselves as
a culture and I think preventing
childhood trauma and changing the ways
that we educate children and adults
would could again make a sea change and
maybe set us on a course towards even
towards a greater likelihood of survival
as a species yeah so talking to like uh
people in elementary school
about human nature
and teaching them was so uh how people
can be resentful and envious and how how
to deal with your emotions
uh how to uh yeah these basic
interaction things about human
relationships about friendships about
betrayal about love about all those
things like it just it's actually
strange that we don't we kind of hope
the parents talk about that kind of
stuff right but then the parents often
uh you know need therapy themselves the
parents just didn't learn it right I
mean I'm not joking that I was I was mad
you know second year after medical
school like how is it like I think even
things in my own life and you know how I
you know like how much shame I felt
after my brother's suicide like I was
already an adult right as a young adult
but I felt so much shame I didn't like I
had no understanding that that oh look
it's it's a it's a reflex to trauma
right to feel guilt and shame and that
of course I was feeling that it didn't
mean it was true because I felt it but I
mapped the fact that I felt ashamed to
the fact that I should have felt guilty
and ashamed and I like led to some very
negative things in my life and I had to
sort of pull myself back from and
recover from and like I didn't know that
right I didn't know the automaticity of
the reflex and how pervasive it can be
and how it can put blinders on us and I
mean it's just one example but you know
it's example of something big that
happens to people that we don't learn
learn about and I find myself sometimes
having conversations with a person
because I still do a lot of clinical
care of having conversations with a
person after a tragedy and I'm saying I
can't believe right again I'm saying the
things that this person didn't learn in
elementary school because like none of
us did right and then look at the misery
and the suffering and then I think this
is one person among how many millions
Among Us who you know who try and go
about their way without knowing things
that are easily knowable because they
don't even know that they're knowable
because we don't teach them to ourselves